welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness
is one verse in the mcu that we can
still look forward to
with a ton of huge updates recently
coming out about its plot its cast its
production timeline
and the fictional timelines that this
movie will explore hopefully less
depressing than the increasingly darkest
timeline we
live in i'm gonna break down everything
you need to know about doctor strange
and multiverse madness and spoiler
warning in case any of this is too right
or gives you too much hope
okay so we just learned that doctor
strange the multiverse of madness is set
to begin production
in the uk this november still as of now
on schedule for its new release date of
march 25th
2022 under the working title of
stellar stellar vortex okay doctor
strange we get it you want your
multiverse of madness to feel as much
like an acid trip as possible
yes working titles don't always
translate directly to plot implications
but we have also learned they can
sometimes have relevant meaning
like in the batman working title
vengeance
i'm vengeance only that cowl covered the
mouth
speaking of vengeance marvel's vengeance
number one in 2011 was the debut of the
character many believe the working title
stellar vortex for the doctor strange
sequel to be further confirmation of her
joining the mcu
america chavez aka miss america
that speculation began earlier this year
around the time director sam raimi took
over from original director scott
derrickson
and when rick and morty writer mike
waldron was announced as the writer for
both multiverse of madness and head
writer for the loki series on disney
plus
a casting report for multiverse of
madness said they were looking for a
hispanic teenage female for a major
supporting role
and most believe that to be america's
chavez she is a multiverse hopping hero
capable of kicking open
star-shaped holes in reality star-shaped
holes that you could also call
stellar vortexes in the comics america
chavez comes from the utopian parallel
a separate reality detached from time
she was raised by her mothers and she
absorbed the magical powers of the
demiurge her reality is threatened by
destruction when she's six years old but
her mom's
sealed those black holes resulting in
their deaths and their particles
blasting across the multiverse america
begins hopping the multiverse and ends
up joining the young avengers which we
know marvel studios appears to be
setting up in its upcoming titles
wiccan and speed and wandavision kate
bishop and hawkeye cassie lang stature
and ant-man 3
maybe elijah bradley patriot and falcon
winter soldier maybe an iron lad role
with kang introduced in loki or harley
keener returning from iron man 3 at tony
stark's funeral and end game now beyond
america's chavez we've also gotten
confirmation that chihuatel 84 is
returning as mordo
in multiverse of madness with other
rumors pointing to jericho drum
brother voodoo brother to daniel drumm
previous new york sanctum guardian in
the first film who was killed by
kaiselius as well as rumors about the
appearance of steven strange's lover and
sorceress clea
but of course the most important
newcomer to the multiverse of madness is
still confirmed to be
elizabeth olsen wanda maximoff the
scarlet witch and combined with these
other reports i think we're now getting
a much clearer picture of the film's
plot
well before i continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
that's bang every can of bang is 16
ounces it contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine it's sugar-free and it has
zero calories yet it tastes great
mmm bang with over 20 different flavors
to choose from one of those great
flavors is
peach mango it tastes like peach it
tastes like mango
as if the man of steel himself took both
those fruits and threw them through your
skull and they smashed into your brain
and now you
have powers check out bang on instagram
you can get 25
off your order at bang energy.com when
you use the code newrockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including sweet tea
keto coffee flavors you can also get
clothing fitness supplements all kinds
of stuff to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video
get 25 off at bang energy.com using the
code
newrockstars25 okay so what do we know
about doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness well in past videos i've
speculated on the horror possibilities
of this storyline but
scott derrickson's exit might mean some
of the demonic hellish elements
might have gone with him but that
doesn't mean one division cannot explore
the occult
especially since as a disney plus
streaming series they have a lot more
creative flexibility
and wouldn't necessarily have to worry
about the chinese film board sensorine
which is something they tend to do with
films with ghostly and demonic elements
definitely something doctor strange too
as a wide release film would have to
worry about
presently i believe that one division
will explore wanda maximoff's witchcraft
wish fulfillment her deal with the devil
an attempt to resurrect her late lover
vision
through katherine hahn as agatha
harkness servant
to mephisto twitter user michaela
mcdonald tweeted me
a really cool theory about wand division
taking place within that moment
wanda destroys vision's mind stone and
infinity war and thanos reverses
time to reassemble it and yeah in past
videos i have speculated that wanda's
furious line to thanos and in-game
you took everything from me
could have been referring to a dark
hidden subplot in which her
return from the void after the blip came
without her vision babies that were in
her womb
at the moment of the snap yes i did bury
that pitch pretty deep in the video
because the comments would get pretty
interesting if i were to lead with
thanos giving wanda an unwanted abortion
but i suspect one of vision will
conclude with a moment
similar to the start of house of m with
wanda's manipulation via agatha and
mephisto
and channel flipping reality hopping
will result in a heartbreak
and psionic meltdown the universe will
fragment into chaos
and each successive marvel title could
find itself in its own
isolated reality until someone comes
along and stitches it back together that
surgeon
dr steven strange this will all set the
stage for doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness in which
the scarlet witch will be the villain of
this story
an emotionally detached don't give a
[ __ ] cosmic witch
so broken inside that only a sorcerer
supreme
with a background as a healer can fix
that broken heart
so i believe strange will be in a race
through different various realities to
get to wanda first
against mordo who believes killing wanda
is the only way to fix the multiverse
after all he did end the first film by
saying
i see it long last what's wrong with the
world
too many sorcerers but as we learned in
our re-watch of doctor strange earlier
this year strange's big lesson in that
film
the thing that makes him different from
all other marvel heroes is his ability
to see
past death to achieve more holistic and
complex solutions to crises
his is the only film that didn't end
with him destroying or incapacitating
his antagonist
he bargained with dormammu he broke
dormammu's brain
similarly i think strange's mission in
the multiverse of madness will be a
similar kind of bargain
but with his fellow mystic avenger but i
don't think he'll be able to convince
wanda alone
this is where america chavez comes in a
new multiverse hopper strange will meet
on his search for wanda maximoff in the
multiverse
america tragically lost her parents when
they disintegrated and spread out among
the stars in the cosmos and she learned
a critical lesson at a young age that
wanda will need to hear
in order to fully process vision's death
when we lose those who we love
they are not gone now they live
everywhere
they're part of the universe that you
continue to live in and if you look
around you'll continue to see them in
surprising places and forms
but most importantly you'll carry them
with you always and yes while we are
kind of in this metaphysical headspace i
realize the biggest story in the marvel
world has been the tragic death of
chadwick boseman
our black panther t'challa and so many
other wonderful roles he's a beloved
actor and human being that i will try to
carry on with me always
i'm still not quite ready to speculate
on what marvel studios will do for black
panther 2 or future marvel titles that
black panther was speculated to be part
of
if you comment or tweet me with those
theories i'm just not going to engage
with you right now i'm sorry
but i promise we will talk about it just
not yet okay
thank you so much for your patience but
if you do have thoughts on this dr
strange want to vision theory comment
down below and come join us on our new
rockstar's official discord server
talk about all things nerdy you can do
that by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos follow me rockstars
and subscribe for breakdowns of
everything marble thanks for watching
[Music]
boom
you